[Musica]
stasera tutti buongiorno a tutti anche
se non vi vedo se vivessi vi chiederei
con lo sguardo di dirmi che cosa ci
faccio qui per due motivi il primo è che
tutti i miei compagni di ted oggi sono
fighissimi e io faccio fumetti il
secondo è che di solito io essendo
l'editore faccio raccontare le storie
agli altri e oggi voi siete così gentili
da fare finta che vi interessi la mia
non è facile da raccontare e secondo me
è abbastanza noiosa cercherò di non
annoiarvi per i prossimi 9 minuti e 31
secondi 30 29 28
mi devo usare tutti e non e devo usare
uno di più premi tirano via io sono nato
a treviso ci ho vissuto i primi 28 anni
della mia vita ho fatto il liceo
scientifico a treviso che per chi in
sala conosca quell'edificio rappresenta
un unicum architettonico nel mondo che
non salveremo dai tedeschi in caso di
terza guerra mondiale e nella città che
ha inventato la scarpa che respira
abbiamo anche la scuola che suda perché
al liceo scientifico di treviso piove il
giorno dopo che ha piovuto fuori
abitualmente ho avuto un'adolescenza
assolutamente normale abbastanza noiosa
non ero in primo banco con il procedere
della mia miopia sono diventato sempre
meno secchione
fino a che un anno mi hanno dato quattro
materie settembre e ogni professore di
quella commissione ha detto solo io ho
salvato suo figlio signora quindi in
realtà avevate tutti la pallottola a
salve il plotone d'esecuzione non mi
avrebbe mai ucciso probabilmente in ogni
caso non leggevo fumetti all'epoca però
leggere un sacco e per esempio
frequentavo tantissimo la biblioteca del
liceo e cisco privo delle cose ero molto
bravo comunicare con il mondo esterno
ignorando le barriere che dovevano
separare un sedicenne dalle persone
importanti e questa cosa dell'erosione
delle barriere me la sono sempre portata
dietro una volta in biblioteca al liceo
trovai un libro in inglese con
l'etichetta della storica libreria
inglese di charing cross road files
scrissi all'indirizzo chiedendo cos'è
questa etichetta che ho trovato mi
rispose cristina poi il seconda
generazione di una schiatta di librai
che dura da 200 anni dicendo che la mia
lettera li aveva ricordato la sua
infanzia a 16 anni
poiché sei un adolescente sei triste
scrissi una raccolta di poesie e la
manda year editore sellerio di palermo
mi rispose con una bellissima lettera di
rifiuto che ho ancora elvira sellerio
ora che faccio l'editore so che quella
non era la lettera di rifiuto a uno che
ti ha mandato una cosa che non vuoi
pubblicare era la lettera di una persona
matura a un sedicenne che non vuoi
mortificare la signora sellerio non c'è
più ma io le sono tuttora grato per quel
gesto
oppure una volta trovai su una rivista
all'indirizzo dello studio dello
scrittore americano michael crichton
quello che ha creato yard e prima ancora
che si parlasse del film io avevo letto
il romanzo jurassic park di straforo
durante ore di matematica mi scuso
tantissimo con la propria in sala e
scrissi a michael crichton dicendo che
mi era piaciuto molto il suo libro
abbiamo corrisposto per due anni questo
era pre internet e probabilmente era
stupito l'idea che un all'epoca
sedicenne italiano l'avesse raggiunto
quindi avevo questa cosa che riuscivo a
colmare le distanze per ora molto
velleitario facevo bene le cose che mi
piacevano e mi interessavo di tutto il
resto non ero ribelle avevo questa
questo bisogno di colmare una distanza
con gli altri di spiegarmi a me stesso
ea loro è un giorno scoperto i fumetti
li ho scoperti durante un'assemblea di
istituto e mi hanno chiarito che
esistevano certi poeti americani quindi
l'ho preso altissima non li leggevo al
mare d'estate
c'era una cosa bellissima nei fumetti
quando io spiego agli studenti come si
racconta a fumetti dico che tu hai tutto
un film hai tutti i fotogrammi non parlo
di pellicola sennò mi dato con gli
studenti di oggi e di risvegliare i
fotogrammi che vanno dall inizio alla
fine per raccontare tutta la storia in
maniera corretta senza che ci siano
salti temporali tra le vignette
eccessivi che impediscano la gente di
capire come c'era transizione tra una
scena e un'altra quindi il fumetto
stabilisce una distanza tra degli attimi
e sta a voi lettori colmare quella
distanza non tanto con l'immaginazione
ma con la logica si crea un rapporto
fiduciario tra me e narratore e voi
fruitori la distanza è anche un problema
tra le persone
solo che tra le persone va colmata
ristretta
bisogna creare ponti ponti non muri e un
altro bel tema per quest'anno
allora mi piaceva molto questo mezzo di
comunicazione che creava questo rapporto
in cui l'autore ammicca al fruitore che
deve fidarsi di lui e avevo capito che
se un narratore raccontava con profonda
franchezza era possibile arrivare in
maniera purissima e diretta al cuore dei
lettori questa cosa a me adolescente
piaceva moltissimo
avevo imparato da mia mamma al gusto per
raccontare una bella storia tra l'altro
lei mi raccontava i film che aveva visto
la sera prima al cinema colazione tutti
e io poi andavo a vederli lo stesso e
vorrei scusarmi ufficialmente con tutti
i miei amici perché per colpa di questo
io faccio spoiler di continuo perché
secondo me la storia resta bella invece
da mio papà volo imparato il desiderio
di costruire con le mie mani
ho cominciato a scrivere fumetti è
cominciato scrivendo topolino paperinik
ma la versione di k quindi era un po più
figo e soprattutto i fotoromanzi di
barbie dovrai faccio outing
l'ho fatto per due anni mi prendo il
merito che quando per un po barbie ha
lasciato caen e io ho dato una
personalità al nuovo fidanzato perché lo
avevano creato ma era tabula rasa e io
ho infuso tutta la sfiga sentimentale
che avevo avuto negli anni del liceo ed
è servito perché quando poi si è rimesso
un giorno tornavo da treviso a milano
tutti erano tristi in redazione mi
dicono barbie barbie deve tornare con
chemio mi sono alzato dicendo quella
ragazza non è una poco di buono
e però ho scritto la storia come venivo
lasciato rifiutato io ha funzionato
perfettamente applausi bellissima avuto
un sacco di complimenti non saprò mai se
sarei stato un grande sceneggiatore
perché un certo punto ho capito che
volevo essere più di me e ho cominciato
a lavorare con gli autori per agevolarli
per essere un misto tra la loro mamma
l'amante il bancomat e lo psicologo che
il ruolo dell'editore descritta in
quattro parole adesso un lavoro per
questo io in parte ho mentito agli
organizzatori di questo telex sul tema
che avrei trattato perché non parlerò di
graphic journalism perché secondo me il
fumetto importanti anche quando racconta
la realtà al di là dei titoli dei
giornali
però è vero che quando nel 2009 assieme
a caterina abbiamo fondato bao avevamo
capito che volevamo far amplificare
delle voci che sarebbero state
importanti quando un anno fa il nostro
autore più importante 0 calcare ha
pubblicato un libro sul suo reportage
dalla siria e lui era un cristo
qualunque che era andato in siria con i
curdi con degli amici e il loro
principale tema di discussione arrivati
in siria era ma tu hai già fatto la
cacca qui scusate so che non devo dire
qui
in ogni caso il libro era il punto di
vista di una persona normale che era
andata in una situazione straordinaria
io quando lui era in siria guardavo
l'esponte del cellulare sui suoi
messaggi ma neanche quando sei un
fidanzato geloso perché dice vabbè ha
letto il messaggio ancora le mani
poi è tornato e il libro è stato un
enorme successo quest'anno ad aprile una
guerrigliera di cui solo lui aveva
raccontato in italia che tutti
conoscevano come cappuccio rosso è morta
era stata condannata a 99 anni di
carcere per essere stata tra i
dimostranti di piazza taksim in turchia
tutti hanno cominciato a cercare 0
calcare perché di in una dichiarazione
lui si rifiutava per un intero giorno lo
protetto dicendo parolacce al telefono e
giornalisti dicendo noi siamo sciacalli
non è così che vendiamo i libri ma si
era l'ho chiamato e tutti i telegiornali
parlavano di questa persona perché lui
ne aveva fatto un personaggio questa
cosa gli ho detto ricordati che è
importante ricordatelo al di là delle
polemiche degli sciacalli del ciclo
delle notizie ed è la cosa che mi ha
fatto capire che essere un buon editor e
un buon editore è una cosa fondamentale
io all'inizio volevo essere come gordon
lish l'uomo che limava lo stile di
raymond carver rendendolo quello che è
stato
o come carmen balcells la gente spagnola
che ha inventato la letteratura
latinoamericana e alla quale gabriel
garcía márquez chiedeva carmen ma tu mi
vuoi bene perché lei l'aveva creato e
lei risponde vagava non ti posso
rispondere a questa domanda perché tu
rappresenti il 36,2 per cento del nostro
fatturato
volevo essere tra all'artista geniale e
l'uomo d'affari mecenate delle arti ma
in realtà devi essere molto molto di più
devi portare nelle case della gente
delle storie che chiariscano che le vite
di tutti
ci sono in qualche modo collegate la
fine di un amore
l'inizio di una nuova avventura umana
sono piccoli germi intellettuali che
devono stare nei pensieri di tutti è il
mezzo narrativo che uso io è
estremamente diretto la ragione per cui
lo uso è che mi piacerebbe tantissimo a
41 anni proiettarmi nel passato per un
istante facciamo i supereroi come i
fumetti che leggevano adolescente dire
almè sedicenne sarai un sacco di sbagli
ma andrà tutto bene
a 41 anni conoscerà il cantante di reims
dovrai lottare per capire quale
telegiornale parla dei tuoi libri ma io
quel ragazzo non lo incontrerò mai più
posso parlare solamente con tutte le
persone con il privilegio di incontrare
da adesso in avanti
oggi si e san martino ma oggi è anche il
giorno dei single in cina non scherzate
è il black friday cinese col fuso orario
la giornata da fare in cina è finita e
solo il più grande vendere online ha
fatto 18 miliardi di dollari di cose
inutili
se tutti quei soldi fossero stati spesi
in storie il mondo sarebbe diventato
migliore durante il mio intervento
il messaggio che voglio portare con le
cose che faccio è ai giovani ai meno
giovani anche i capelli a chi non li ha
bianchi o di altri colori
siete meno strani di quello che vi hanno
detto siete meno soli di quello che
temete e siete più forti di quello che
sapete io passerò il resto della vita a
dirlo occhi negli occhi a tutte le
persone che vorranno ascoltarmi
grazie infinite
[Applauso]
[Musica]